in 1905 there was almost a world war
between Japan and Russia two of the
great powers on earth at the time it was
one of the first major industrial Wars
incredibly fierce and bloody and it
really exhausted both the Japanese and
Russian empires and bled them dry and it
came very close to drawing in the other
major powers and starting a world war
Theodore Roosevelt who is the president
of the United States felt that the US
could serve a very useful role in
mediating the dispute both sides trusted
Teddy Roosevelt and he saw this as an
opportunity to bring America to play a
larger role on the world scene through
diplomacy both sides governments wanted
a negotiation but neither wanted to make
the first move
and so what Roosevelt did is he turned
to each of them and said if this is what
you want you can approach me and then I
will make it possible for both of you to
take the first step and make concessions
without losing face that was very
important the negotiation was held in
Portsmouth New Hampshire it almost
didn't succeed but Theodore Roosevelt
was able to pull it off and won the
first Nobel Peace Prize any American won
for preventing a world war and sheathing
the swords of 1/2 million men
one of the things we can learn from the
success of the Portsmouth tree
negotiations is the value of a mediator
this was a situation where while
elements of both sides wanted to
continue the war both governments
realize that peace was really in their
interest Theodore Roosevelt as as a
mediator provided that and often um we
can find that in our own lives in
negotiations we carry out as well in our
legal system mediation is is often
offered as a less expensive less
harrowing alternative to a full-blown
lawsuit and it allows the parties to
reach a compromise and reach a
settlement without having to go to trial
but even informally I mean if there's an
intractable dispute and egos are high
and emotions are are wound up seeking
out a third party to provide a
convenient out for both sides is often
very effective